Oh
well in the industrialized world we have
a number of problems when it comes to
reproductive health and i have to say we
have to distinguish the united states
from other countries because other
countries are not as schizophrenic about
say the subject of abortion most
industrialized countries have relatively
reasonable access to abortion it is an
incredibly important part of
reproductive healthcare it's not the
only service but there are some women
who need access to abortion for variety
of reasons and that really ought to be
available and it should be covered by
any health plan we have a huge problem
in which I won't get into right now we
also have to make sure that women have
better access to contraceptives even if
they can't afford some of the more
expensive ones and they have access to
good information and that we do a better
job educating the public about the need
what we call dual protection protection
against unwanted pregnancy if that's
what we want and protection against
sexually transmissible infections not
just HIV AIDS but host of other things
chlamydial infections certain going to
prevent HPV infections and those are
things we we really need to do a better
job on when it comes to maternity care
we've actually slid backwards in the
United States it looks like a maternal
mortality rate is starting to climb in
certainly in some states we've
demonstrated that and the reasons a
multifactorial but the most important
thing I want to underscore here is that
this is an example where our high-tech
inappropriately intervent of approach
has produced a downside we're doing way
too many cesareans it's about 13
nationally but we have many states and
many communities where it is now forty
fifty percent cesarean section rate I
know in New Jersey there are hospitals
that have fifty to seventy percent
cesarean rates this is unacceptable and
of course it's going to produce harm
because cesarean section is a major
abdominal surgery even if the surgery
goes well you have all kinds of
infections that occur in hospital
settings and we have an increase in
Mercer methicillin-resistant
staphylococcus aureus MRSA infections
are not often easily treatable with
antibiotics in fact some of our big guns
like vancomycin aren't doing such a good
job and you need IV
intravenous antibiotics and long stays
in hospitals sometimes to recover this
can happen after a caesarean just like
after any surgery these are kinds of
things women don't appreciate so we're
trying to educate women to think about
what our best practices in maternity
care the best way to avoid an
unnecessary caesarean section is to
choose a midwife whether it's a
free-standing birth center or in a
hospital setting where midwives can
really practice midwifery or a home
birth setting and we've got good data
that palm births for low-risk
uncomplicated pregnancies are as safe as
hospital births that data have been in
for several years now and it's really a
turf problem that we've got where we see
obstetricians scaring women into
thinking this is risky tena mounted
child abuse ridiculous things when
women's suggests that it might be
reasonable to have a home birth or
freestanding birth center birth these
are actually wiser approaches and we've
been involved in producing a 14 minute
DVD largely designed for Massachusetts
legislators who are considering a
midwifery bill right now but it's
something we hope to have on YouTube
soon so that the larger public can
understand from the perspective of
consumers and doctors we have no
midwives speaking in this DVD it's only
physician couples who have used mid wise
and other couples who are very well
educated and physicians who understand
the benefits of midwifery care speaking
about the benefits of the midwifery
model and it's that kind of DVD or video
that we want more of the public to see
so they understand that what they're
getting from mainstream sources of
information is not necessarily the best
thing when it comes to how to go about
having a baby in this country today
I was speaking at a conference of
reproductive health providers just
yesterday where we talked about the
front page article in The New York Times
describing the lancet study which gave
us our first really good news that all
the things we've been doing many
different interventions are finally
having an impact on reducing maternal
mortality in developing country settings
now about forty to fifty percent of the
maternal mortality is created in six
countries and one of them is India which
of course has nearly a billion people
they've done a really good job in recent
decades in lowering the maternal
mortality rate so they have a big impact
on the overall figure for maternal
mortality worldwide it's a great thing
The Lancet article came out none of us
at this meeting thought it would harm
the investment in reduction of maternal
mortality in fact finally we've got
evidence that things we've been doing
are being successful so that we should
be pouring in more resources investing
more money in these approaches to
reducing maternal mortality it's not
about reducing our commitment now that
we've shown this works we're going to
increase our commitment and there are
also some interesting things about this
study we should not forget and that is
that in places like Eastern and
sub-saharan Africa big killer of
pregnant women is hiv/aids it's and so
the solution is not getting women
obstetric ille immediate obstetric
emergency coverage it's about getting
antiretrovirals to pregnant women
because sixty thousand deaths in that
region were caused by hiv/aids related
problems it wasn't because a woman was
in labor had obstructed labor was
hemorrhaging had an infection and
couldn't get appropriate medical care it
was really the hiv/aids problem so it
depends on where you are as to how
you're going to intervene in the problem
of maternal mortality and pregnant women
who are struggling with hiv/aids have to
really get that addressed in some cases
first and foremost
well in less industrialized countries
there's no question that if we don't
support the health of women who are the
mothers of children in future
generations and very often they do
double triple duty they're working in
the fields they are taking care of the
home they're providing they're the ones
who have to put food on the table they
don't get access to education we know
now that the single most important thing
we can do is make sure that young girls
stay in school that they get an
education that will more than anything
else help them improve their own ability
to be healthy their ability of healthy
pregnancies to be mothers who aren't
stranded with few resources and families
they can't feed this would be the most
important thing we could do and it means
overcoming a lot of sexism a lot of very
negative attitudes about women and the
need to put women in powerful positions
and communities women are often not
allowed leadership positions in
government community State National
these things have to change and when we
see change there we see usually a
trickle-down effect and that women do
better the communities do better
children do better overall health
improves